[Music]
hi
my name is aaron jacobs i work at
crescendo technology in toronto
which is a company focused on the
technology side of sports betting
i'm also the author of xr prof which is
a new profiling tool for the r ecosystem
that i'm hoping to tell you about today
it's an honor and a privilege to be part
of this year's
unusual our studio conference now
from my perspective there's been an
important change in the r ecosystem in
the last
five or so years r has traditionally
been a language for data analysis
visualization summary exploration
locally interactively with some
reporting
but with the emergence of frameworks
like shiny and plumber it's now being
used more and more to build real
applications
now on the one hand this has created
huge opportunities for our users to
expand the scope of what they can
do and the value that they can bring to
themselves and their organizations
but with this increased opportunity has
come much increased complexity
and increased responsibility the reality
is that
for many our users presenting these
applications means that these
applications have users
other than their authors for the first
time and often they're running in
environments that are
not the same local development
environments that we're used to
this means that you now get bug reports
like hey
why is your shiny app slow or
this report is taking an hour to run but
it used to take two minutes
what's happening now traditionally to
answer
performance related questions like this
you would make use of a profiling tool
profiling itself is a term from computer
science it effectively means
that we collect data about where our
program is spending its time
effectively which functions are being
called most often
now for our users this is actually kind
of a comfortable situation because
profiling produces data and our users
know how to deal with data
we can use all of our favorite tools for
analysis
visualization summary of profiling data
just like we could with any other kind
and profiling itself is a fundamentally
empirical approach to performance
analysis
don't guess measure and then use those
measurements to make informed decisions
profiling is such an important field for
performance analysis that actually
r has its own built-in sampling profiler
it's available through the rproff
function and there's a variety of
functions in base r
and the wider ecosystem that allow you
to make use of our profs
format to produce again these analysis
these summaries these visualizations and
so the prof tools package or the profits
package there's also a profit gui
profiler which are slightly less popular
these all do exactly this summary
analysis
visualization and actually because
there's a wider profiling ecosystem
beyond r
lots of these packages can actually
produce conversions
to popular formats that are used in
external tools so for example
the ability to convert rprof formats to
k cache grind or
google's peeproff tool or the speeds
speed scope format or also the the
original flame graph software format
these are all available in the r
ecosystem so there's a big
existing set of tools you can use for
performance analysis
using the rproff function now all of
this sounds great
but let's get back to that whole shiny
performance issue for a moment
one of the interesting things about
shiny is that it's often used by
co-workers or peers or other otherwise
as an internal tool
which means that the users are often
people who essentially would send you an
email
or a message on slack if they were
issuing you some kind of report
and for example if you receive some sort
of you know performance bug report
it's basically going to come down to hey
your app is slow
can you make it faster so that i can do
my job
and of course this is like not really a
helpful
or informative thing for them to tell
you so you start asking follow-up
questions like hey what were you doing
and they'll tell you
you know i had clicked x and y you'll
ask them things like
okay that's not really enough
information for me to recreate your
issue
do you remember what you set these
inputs to and sometimes they can
remember and tell you perfectly but much
more often
usually they either don't remember or
they misremember and they tell you what
they did but really
they didn't and you spent a long time
running down this rabbit hole of trying
to recreate their issue locally
and the fundamental reason for this is
that when you're using rprof
you have to be doing profiling locally
so you're trying to reproduce an issue
or
an environment and then profiling
locally
to collect data that you can use to
analyze your program
now there's all kinds of reasons why
this is frustrating but in addition to
the frustration there's also the problem
that like
your local environment may kind of
differ from wherever your code ends up
really running for these users
so a classic example of this is say for
myself i often write and develop
applications
in canada but deploy them to servers
that are in europe for european users
this means that you know the kind of
databases that they're connecting to
or the other network services they might
that they might contact
might have very very different latency
profiles when they're actually deployed
as opposed to when i'm working on them
locally and this can kind of create
both bugs but also hide performance
issues where stuff that works fast for
you locally
doesn't work very fast at all for your
users so in addition to the difficulty
of trying to recreate
what your user was doing you're also
trying to recreate this environment
and overall this is a fairly error-prone
process and it really slows
down tracking down performance issues
so this kind of disconnect between where
code is really running
and where you want to profile it is
actually the fundamental motivation
behind a new project that i've been
working on called xrprof
now xr prof is not a clever name it just
means external
rprof and it is exactly that it's a
standalone program that allows you to
profile
our code that is already running so the
fundamental
way of thinking about this is that our
prof allows you
to profile by modifying your r code
usually locally in an interactive
session
xrprof on the other hand is designed and
oriented around
profiling our code that is already
running without modification
and this is very powerful if for example
you want a profile code that's running
in a production environment say on shiny
server on rstudio connect
for our applications that are running
under docker xrprof can see
and understand our programs that are
running in all of those conditions
and profile them for you without
modifying them this allows you to
actually do your profiling with real
users
and real data makes it much easier to
attract on performance issues
because you have data that's close to
the source
now xr prof is fundamentally designed to
be
a compatible drop-in replacement for
rprof which means
it produces the same format and it works
with all of the existing
r ecosystem tools and by extension
through conversions to other formats all
of the wider profiling
world outside of our because of this
compatibility
it's really really easy to use and it
should be very familiar
if you've used profiling data in our
before now there's another piece of this
puzzle
one of the other major things that's
happening in the r ecosystem
is that more and more r packages are
making use of c
and c plus code now it's always been
possible to embed
native code in r it's actually one of
the strengths of r as a programming
language
but i think partly because of
democratizing tools like
rcpp which have made it much easier for
our users to write c
plus code it's now much more common to
include c
plus plus in an r package this is great
on the one hand for performance but it
does create a problem
which is that our prof can actually only
see functions
that are happening inside of the r code
so we can only see our functions
that means that the more and more of
this code that is happening in c and c
plus plus
the more is totally invisible to rprof
and this creates serious issues when the
c and c
plus plus code is actually the source of
the performance problem
now i know you might be thinking hold on
c and c plus plus are much faster than r
and this is true but in practice c
and c plus code can make exactly the
kind of poor performance decision you
can make in r
you can do stuff you don't really need
to do you can do things much more often
than you really need to do them
or you can choose you know a kind of
inefficient
data structure to represent the problem
or an algorithm to actually solve the
problem
so just because code is written in cnc
plus it doesn't mean that it somehow
becomes free of these issues
and i think that if you were trying to
track down
a c or c plus plus related performance
issue in an r package
it's actually been kind of painful so
far either you just guess
what the problem is and keep trying
various approaches or
you try and use some sort of c or c plus
plus
level profiling tool and an r level
profiling tool at the same time
and then try and cross-reference what's
happening this is actually in practice a
very inexact
and frustrating process there's just not
enough enough information on either side
for you to be able to knit these things
together
and this secondary frustration was
actually a big
um technology motivation of xr prof as
well
so xrprof can actually see what is
happening in your cnc
plus code and what it can do is append
that
to your r level functions so you can see
a more holistic picture
of what's going on i think this is a
really really powerful tool especially
for our package developers
who need to do performance analysis that
like crosses this language barrier
and don't forget that r itself is
actually written in c so
in practice sometimes when you're having
performance issues
the touch base r code actually the issue
is in the c
so again what does this kind of look
like
this is a more involved example and
in fact it was a very real issue that i
first encountered a couple of years ago
so at work we have a whole bunch of
semi-structured data
in a database called mongodb
and there's an existing r package called
[ __ ] lite
which can be used to query mongodb it
actually works really really well
the vast majority of the time now if
you're not familiar with mongodb
effectively what it does is store
data as a kind of json which means that
tabular data the kind you would see in a
csv or in a sql table
is essentially represented as an array
a javascript array of javascript objects
so
this effectively looks like a big long
list of dictionaries of key value pairs
where every key value or every you know
row is represented as a dictionary
now it turns out that there's a known
performance issue with
[ __ ] lite for large databases
with lots of columns the queries can
take a long time
a surprisingly long time at least and
when i first encountered this a couple
of years ago i wanted to figure out why
so i profiled it using our prof
but i actually discovered that
i couldn't really see anything and the
reason for this
is that all of the interesting parts
of [ __ ] light are actually implemented
in c
which means that it was very hard to
figure out what was going on
and so at the time i did exactly this
very awkward dance of using cnc plus
plus
related tools and related tools and
trying to cross-reference them
and it was very painful and took me a
long time and
i wasn't even really ever sure if i was
measuring the right thing
so when i redid the analysis for this
talk it was kind of
comforting that what had taken me
several days a few years ago
took me something like 90 seconds when i
used xrprof
and so what what would i see and so
this is what happens when you use rprof
this is a flame graph of what you would
see
which is not that informative because
you just don't see what's happening
inside of the r code that's mostly
implemented in c
but if you can see the c code this is
what you will see
so here the r functions are in blue and
the c functions are in orange
now of course i know this is much too
small for you to actually be able to
read function names and that's not not
really the point
so i'll just point out a couple of
things that i was able to pick up on
once i had
this view the first is that
there's a certain amount of time that r
is
communicating with [ __ ] itself and this
is important because
effectively this represents the total
upper bound
of how fast we could ever possibly make
this r code because the reality is we
still need to spend time
transmitting data from the database over
the network and there's nothing really
we can do about the time that it takes
to do that
other than say querying less data
so this kind of serves as a total upper
bound
but there were two kind of odd things
that i noticed
when i are picked up on when i looked at
these profiles which is that
r is spending a lot of time allocating
memory
and if you don't know what that means
well mostly it doesn't matter
because allocating memory is normally
really fast and in order for
allocating memory to show up on a
profile it means it needs to be
happening
a lot or at least happening really
inefficiently so when i saw this
it immediately peaked my interest and it
made me think what could what could be
causing this many
allocations the second thing that i
noticed
is that mongolia seems to be spending a
ton of time
transposing lists and checking for
uniqueness
which seems like an odd operation to be
doing because again
checking uniqueness is normally pretty
fast in order to spend so much time
doing it you have to be doing it
a lot so originally actually i puzzled
over this for
a while before i realized that
ultimately it actually
totally made sense so remember how i
said that
json data represents tabular data as an
array
of objects well it turns out that how
[ __ ] lite works is that when it reads
in rows
it takes these javascript or these json
objects
and turns them into our lists which is a
very natural representation
of a row basically you know you have
20 columns and that gives you a list
of length 20 and you know every element
that list can have a different type and
you know the names of your lists are the
names of your column
[Music]
and then what happens at the end is
basically it takes all of these lists
and it smooshes them together in a data
frame
now this is
kind of interesting because
if you imagine if we were to create a
data frame
in advance we knew how many rows we were
getting we would essentially
just do one allocation for every column
right so if we had 20 columns we do 20
allocations
but if we read in a million rows of 20
columns
using this approach we do something like
20 million
allocations so you can kind of see where
you know maybe some of this was showing
up in the profile because
instead of doing 20 allocations we're
doing 20 million
and the second thing is because we have
all these lists
when we smoosh them together we have to
do a bunch of things like
check that all of the names are the same
and all the types of this are the same
and we have to do this for every single
row we add against all the data that
we've previously added
so again you can see how this adds up
[Music]
now actually this story doesn't have a
super happy ending
i did propose changing [ __ ] light so
that it used a different algorithm
the problem was it was a very complex
patch something like 700 lines of new c
code or something like that so it wasn't
accepted into mongol light
but it was about five times faster which
just goes to show that even though
you're writing something in a fast
language like crc
plus doesn't mean you can't make exactly
the same kind of performance issues that
you'd encounter in our code
so hopefully that serves as some
inspiration as to
what might interest you if you're trying
to do remote profiling
for any kind of production code or
you're trying to do profiling
local or remote that involves our code
that uses lots of crc plus plus
now i should say xr profit itself the
project is
open source it's available on github
most of the development this year was
generously funded by the our consortium
and i'm currently looking for
users to try it out see if it works for
you see if you can break it
and let me know i'm hoping that xr
profit can be
can become a new tool in the our
profiling toolbox
i'm aaron jacobs you can find me on
twitter on github
and on my own site i work at crescendo
technology in toronto
and if this stuff kind of piques your
interest we're always hiring
thanks for listening and i hope you
enjoyed this and all the great talks at
this year to star studio
[Music]
conference